um thank you very much for being on the
program this morning now I'll be honest
I really didn't want to start this
interview after weeks at the borough
show talking about partygate but frankly
with the emergence of the video that has
happened overnight I don't really feel
like we've got much choice now indeed
this is a video that I want to play from
December the 14th 2020 and it shows a
Christmas party at cchq conservative
Campaign Headquarters let's have a watch
Instagram
[Music]
what do you think of this
so what do you think of this
it's terrible
I mean this was laughing talking about
bending the rules there's photos of
social distancing in the room that are
clearly being ignored yeah what's your
reaction well I I think it's um
completely out of order
um as I understand it
um this was a an event that was
organized by the people who were running
the mayoral campaign for Sean Bailey uh
they had obviously behaved in a way
which is unacceptable
um I understand that the people who
organize this were subsequently
investigated and disciplined by
conservative Campaign Headquarters I
don't know if this video is available to
the people doing that investigation and
who were responsible for that
disciplinary procedure but it was
certainly the case that I think a
photograph had um emerged beforehand
showing some of the people at this party
posing with a cake and and behaving in
an unacceptable fashion so I just want
to apologize
um to uh to everyone really uh who
looking at that image will think well
these are people who are
fighting the rules that were put in
place to protect us all
you said that there was a photo of the
event before the video yes didn't emerge
until now
um no fines were issued for this event
do you think the police should
investigate now I'm looking at the video
well it's not for me to say whether or
not the police should investigate but
the the evidence is out there
um as you say and and this is my
understanding uh this video wasn't
available wasn't publicly available
beforehand there was a photograph
um there have been a number of occasions
subsequently to events when information
has been shared and the police have
reviewed again whether or not an
investigation should take place but
quite properly and I and I know this
sounds sort of very uh bureaucratic and
procedural but you'll appreciate I think
people watching will appreciate but
politicians shouldn't tell the police
what they should and shouldn't
investigate the police should be able to
make that decision and then follow
through without politicians providing a
commentary on that you mentioned a
photograph we can have a look at the
photograph I think that has been
available previously now two of the
people in this Photograph have received
honors Sean Bailey who is the candidate
for London yeah left the party before
the video was filmed and also the guy
who is lying at the front of that
picture wearing the Christmas braces uh
Ben Mallett conservative aide yeah
should they be given on us well again
the whole process by which animals are
given is one that I think is rightly the
subject of debate at the moment yes
what's your opinion on it well I think
you have to follow the current rules you
can you can have a debate about changing
the rules um and I think that debate is
well worth having but as long as we have
the current rules they they go something
like this a retiring prime minister any
retiring prime minister can put forward
people for honors
prime minister gets that list prime
minister shouldn't really interfere with
that list um Rishi sunak did not he
accepted it then it goes to the House of
Lords appointments committee which is an
independent body that decides whether or
not someone who's been put forward for a
peerage should get it as I understand it
and I never saw any of these lists uh
the house of law Department's committee
took some names off the you know they
they had their own reasons for doing so
but it was clearly the case that there
were some people who were put forward by
Boris four peerages whom the House of
Lords appointments committee deemed not
appropriate at this time to be appointed
list goes back the prime minister is
operating on the basis that the House of
Lords appointments committee has
satisfied itself that this is a legit
list and then passes it on for a final
approval to the Palace thank you for the
rundown for how the honor system works
um my question was do you think the two
people in this photo should have
received honors well again I think you
should follow appropriate procedures
what do you think I think that's the
question uh I think that in the past we
have had uh at least one uh occasion
where the house of appointments
committees procedures were interviewed
with by a prime minister that procedure
the people in this photo should have
received honors what do you Michael go
think I think you should follow the
procedures but what what do you think I
I think you should follow the procedures
and gets absolutely important that when
you have a process for appointing
someone to any public body including the
House of Lords that you follow the rules
now they didn't follow the rules did
they the rules about how people should
be appointed to the House of Lords were
followed by the Prime Minister now as I
said earlier you and I can argue that
the rules are deficient okay or need to
be changed but what I won't do is pass
commentary on someone else's Choice it's
for Boris to defend his choice of peers
on the same day as this party the 14th
of December 2020 Matt Hancock was giving
a press conference where he said there
had been a 14 rise in covert cases in a
week and 420 daily deaths reported and I
just want to read a tweet that someone
sent me last night this is from a guy
called Paul I mean someone says lots of
people saying very similar things but
this is Paul he contacted me last night
and he tweeted to say uh this 14th
December
2020. I remember the state very well I
wasn't at a party my daughter underwent
major surgery at Great Ormond Street
only one parent was allowed to stay with
her we followed the rules it's downright
disgusting there's charlatans they're
liars and imbeciles there's a lot of
them
what'd you say to Paul sorry
um I can't imagine what it must have
been like for Paul
um on that day
um I think if uh any member of your
family is undergoing major surgery is
undoubtedly traumatic the fact that this
was happening at the height of the
pandemic when the virus was spreading
and people were observing uh significant
rules in order to make sure that they
protected others the fact that this
party went ahead is indefensible
um the people who were there I'm sure
feel uh contrite
um uh I certainly hope they do uh as I
say there was a previous investigation
into this and we now know more about it
but I can only say to to Paul that I'm
I'm very very sorry that there were
people who were working in government
very hard on his behalf not all of whom
uh on every occasion will have made the
right decision in policy terms but all
of the time we were thinking about how
we could help Paul and others there's a
covered inquiry ongoing at the moment
which will look at decisions that
government made I think one of the most
important things that all of us can do
is to look back at the decisions the
government made and make sure that we're
better prepared if a future pandemic
comes along but for Paul and for others
who are grieving who suffered and who
lost
[Music]
relatives or whose own family
had to endure these rules
um I can only apologize now of course it
comes in a week where the Privileges
committee report yes tore into bonus
Johnson I mean you will have read the
reports um according to the Sunday Times
though he thinks he can make a comeback
he's been telling his friends Churchill
didn't become a prime minister until he
was 65. is there room for Boris Johnson
return
well I I I'm not a particularly gifted
Clairvoyant I'm I can't really look into
the future and uh predict with accuracy
as you know Sophie I once wrote a book
called Michael Portillo the future of
the right so I wouldn't set many uh much
store by my predictions
um so Boris has uh taken a decision to
leave the House of Commons uh he's now
writing for the Daily Mail and making
arguments on a variety of of other
issues
um you know I wish him well in in that
endeavor
um and I think that the more important
thing is for the government uh to
concentrate on the priorities that the
public have assigned to us making sure
that we have inflation that we reduce
our debt that we grow the economy and
critically importantly uh given what
we've been talking about that we cut NHS
waiting lists and of course that we stop
the votes that we deal with illegal
migration you've got four looming
by-elections now with the resignation of
David Warburton this is not a great time
for you as a are you confident in
keeping those by-elections yes I am um
and again each of these by-elections has
an individual cause but I think that um
in Summerton Froome and in Selby um in
Oxbridge and in mid bedfordshire I know
that we have and will select excellent
conservative candidates and so I will be
working hard in order to stress to
people uh in those constituencies that
effective conservative representation
means that on the issues that matter on
tackling inflation on making sure that
we get economic growth
we've got the list okay we're going to
talk about something but it's very
important people know come the election
while there may be four by-elections
there are five critical priorities
and on migration I want to talk about
the economy later um but just before I
do David Warburton has given an
interview today where he seems to feel
that he is the wrong party it's not a
great look for you though is it to have
another MP who is resigning amid claims
of sexual impropriety and Drug taking
well again I I haven't read the
interview that Mr Warburton has given to
the mail on Sunday I understand that he
was being investigated and uh when I
think he was acquainted with the results
of that investigation he felt that he
had to resign when that report is
published all of us can then form a
judgment right now I could spend another
five minutes asking you about Boris
Johnson but I really really don't want
to I want to talk about mortgages right
of course more than 800 deals were
pulled from the market at the end of May
TSB withdrew all of its 10-year fixed
deals santanderers pulled mortgage deals
for new borrowers now west put up its
rates by as much as 1.5 percent
are you a bit frightened by what's
happening no I am concerned of course
um and naturally what's happened as a
consequence of the Independent Bank of
England uh are having to put up interest
rates uh in order in its judgment to
deal effectively with inflation the most
important thing as I mentioned earlier
for our economy is that we bring
inflation down uh the best tax cut that
we can give to anyone is to make sure
that the cost of living comes back under
control uh the bank government will make
its own decisions but as a minister who
is responsible for housing I do take a
close interest on what's happening in
the mortgage Market it only reinforces
the importance of doing everything else
that we can to uh to help and to support
homeowners and indeed specifically to
help those in the rental sector as well
who have faced the prospect of
increasing rents that's why we're
bringing forward legislation the private
rented sector reforms in order to help
them I absolutely agree that renters
have faced for many years a very
difficult situations but let's be honest
you know Rising interest rates impacts
renters too because if a landlord
according to the resolution Foundation
the average household remortgaging next
year will see their bills Rise by nearly
3 000 pounds I mean this is an
affordability crisis do you have a
mortgage I don't have a mortgage at the
moment no uh but I quite agree with you
that it is a very difficult situation
for hundreds of thousands of people and
that is why it's vitally important that
the government does everything that it
can in order to help people with the
cost of living to make sure for example
that we deal with energy bills as well
um we are intervening in order to ensure
that people get support
you're going to do specifically for
mortgage owners well uh there are two
things there the first thing is that we
need to look at all of the cost of
living pressures the second thing is
that when it comes to uh mortgages it's
the Independent Bank of England's
interest rate decisions that will govern
that but we are looking at everything
that we can do in order to help uh home
owners through this difficult period one
of the things that will not help
awareness is the labor party policy to
uh borrow uh 28 billion pounds a year
unfunded borrowing which will drive up
interest rates and drive up the cost of
living compounding that increase in the
cost of living will be the labor party's
plan to end uh oil and gas extraction
from the North Sea which will mean that
we'll be reliant on Russia for our
energy you know what though a lot of
people listening to you will think that
is really rich
my mortgages are going up inflation is
going up the economy is in a really
difficult position and who has been in
power for over a decade it's not labor
they don't want to listen to lectures
from you about what the labor party
should be doing on their Economic Policy
just want to look at UK government years
when we're contemplating what an
electoral choices that people know what
the alternatives are and you are right
and I will talk to labor about that you
are right I want to focus on the
economic record of this government if I
may and I have a look at now at this
government is what we're thinking about
which is how much to recognize that
there is a choice there is that's
correct um this is the cost of uh
effectively government borrowing right
and you can see that it's now up to the
same level as it was during the mini
budget of Liz truss and I think honestly
people will look at this and they'll be
a bit confused I'll say hang on I
understood why things were bad during
the list budget but I thought things
were supposed to be getting better I
thought Richard was stabilizing things
what's going on well interest rates are
rising across the globe so um when you
think about the economy we all know that
our economy is interconnected with those
across the world interest rates are
rising in the Eurozone and they're
rising in America and elsewhere and
that's because of the the long-term
shocks that came both as a result of
covet and the war in Ukraine now I'm not
saying that that absorbs this government
or any government of a responsibility
for dealing with it one thing that is
clear though is that the decisions that
were taken by uh Liz truss and
quasi-quarting exacerbated the situation
uh since uh Jeremy Hunters has been
Chancellor and Rishi has been prime
minister then steps have been taken that
have given markets greater confidence so
the trend it is clear to say that
borrowing costs are now at the same
level as on that but they were Rising
anyway so what we've done is we've
ensured that we did not make the
situation worse indeed we made the
situation better against a very strong
headwind which is hitting
economies across the world now it is
but core inflation in the UK higher than
anywhere else in the G7 two percent more
expensive to borrow money for the UK
government than the German government
which is the one that you guys talk
about all the time there are clearly
issues that are disproportionately
affecting the UK economy and do you not
take responsibility for that well of
course I take responsibility of what's
happening in the UK economy but it's
also the case since you mentioned
Germany uh Germany and the Eurozone are
in recession at the moment and we are
not so again you've said that it's a
price worth paying for getting inflation
ground so it sounds like we're gearing
up for doesn't it you can look at
individual statistics in any individual
area as part of of what is I absolutely
acknowledge a very difficult economic
picture but if you want to say that
Britain is facing a difficulty here I
think there is an obligation on all of
us to say yes that's true but it is also
the case that Britain is doing better in
these other areas Britain is doing
better in attracting Tech investment in
particular which is why I think one of
the most important stories and
developments today is on page two of the
Sunday Times where the Prime Minister
has appointed Ian hogoff the lead and an
artificial intelligence task force to
make sure that Britain is and Remains
the key destination for AI investment
particularly when it comes to artificial
intelligence safety so if we look at the
broader economic picture yes there are
difficulties but there are also areas of
strength that Britain has which will
help us to weather the storm okay now
you're launching what you described as a
Crackdown on public bodies pursuing
anti-israeli foreign policy yes what's
the idea well there are two things here
the first thing is that Britain's
foreign policy is uh more effective when
we speak with one voice and there have
been some bodies including local
authorities that have attempted to
subvert or to run their own foreign
policy the second thing is that in many
cases these local authorities have been
doing so specifically in a way which has
increased anti-semitic tensions there is
something called the BDS Campaign which
is a campaign that uniquely holds out
Israel for criticism of course uh there
are multiple reasons to be critical of
some of the decisions that the Israeli
government has made but this specific
campaign is inflected with a particular
degree of vehements towards the state of
Israel the world's only Jewish State and
therefore what we need to do whenever we
encounter a political campaign that
makes anti-Semitism uh more of a threat
to Jewish people in this countries we
need to take action I'm just trying to
get my head around this because it looks
like it's a ban on public bodies
boycotting foreign countries so does
this mean that councils won't be able to
unilaterally boycott countries who don't
share our values like Russia for example
no it means that what they can't do is
they can't take a different position on
foreign policy from that of the UK
government so you trust the central
government but you don't trust local
government to make these decisions the
UK
um foreign policy is something that the
UK government whether it's conservative
labor or Coalition should determine uh
and quite rightly
um it's central government that takes
these important decisions on foreign
policy and the same is its local
government that decides how uh planning
decisions should be made that decides
how critical adult care and children's
care services are delivered so there is
a division of responsibility and uh it's
our foreign secretary and our prime
minister who set our foreign policy and
I may say since you mentioned Russia
that our prime minister our foreign
secretary I think have taken a position
towards Russia and Ukraine which has
been in influencing other countries
consistently for good for years now okay
now one last thing I want to get your
view on because there's been lots of
speculation about what your view is on
this so I want to try and work it out
now uh it is buy one get one free deals
so the government is delaying a ban on
buy one get one free deals on and
actually feed to 2025. what's your view
on that well my view is that we do need
to take action to uh to tackle obesity
uh this was one measure because of the
cost of living challenges which we've
been discussing uh we're reviewing
whether or not this is the best measure
um but if we do move away from this then
I think it is important and I know that
this is something that we're discussing
at the heart of government to take other
steps in order to deal with obesity
um one of the big problems one of the
big challenges that our NHS faces is the
demand for services if we can tackle
obesity that contributes to tackling
diabetes heart disease and a number of
other factors is it true that you're
looking at for example takeaway
locations and stuff like that is that
right well again this helps me actually
to clear up something which was a mild
missed reporting last week it was the
case that it was reported that I
personally had intervened to take a
decision to stop a pizza restaurant
opening in tyneside I did not the local
Authority in tyneside had a policy there
about the location of takeaways and this
is just an example of of local
government taking a different decision
from central government just exactly
what we've been talking about my own
view is that we need to look at a range
of measures in order to tackle uh
obesity I've been very impressed by the
work of Henry dimbleby who was the
leader in the national food strategy
there are a range of tools that we can
use we have to however at a time when as
you quite rightly point out there's
pressure on household budgets be careful
about those steps okay Force Johnson
being lobbying you want any weight loss
drugs like his column in the mail no um
uh I'm when it comes to weight loss or
indeed anything else I think the most
important thing is to follow the advice
of the experts okay there you go uh
thank you very much indeed Michael Gove
on the program this morning
Michael Gove now a fan of experts who
would have thought it